oh no what does the world come to for
your post butthole
my publicist is back there like yeah hi
I'm Courtney Cox hey I'm Jenna Ortega
and I'm Melissa Barrera hey I'm Mason
Savoy Brown hi I'm Jasmine Gooding Cuba
Mason and we are the cast of Scream Six
and we're here to find out which iconic
scream characters we are we are
oh God
firstly what quality do you look for on
a best friend honesty loyalty kindness
sense of Uma forgiveness creativity does
I'm curious picking one do you just
sense of humor relinquish all the others
like are they really creative but they
just lie all the time and like stabbing
I'm gonna say I've had kindness kind of
it like but it encompasses a lot of the
your colors thank you very much kindness
I go for honesty if I'm gonna be
impressed by someone it's gonna be
either by their creativity or sense of
humor okay creativity choose your
favorite Scream movie Cameo Drew Barry
Morris Casey Becker Jada Pinkett Smith
as Maureen Evans Henry Winkler's
principal Hembree Sarah Michelle Geller
as CC Cooper leave Schreiber as cotton
weary Kristen Bell is Chloe I feel like
Drew or Jada I'm gonna go Drew though
I'd say Leah ver Drew I'm gonna say drew
too I won't say drew because YouTube
picked Drew so I'm gonna say
Jade I think it's fifth because I think
it's a night that's such a good death
yeah
uh you guys it's Jada for me
how would you spend your ideal Friday
night happy hour with all my friends
date night with my s o significant other
oh my God I don't know anything having a
chill night and when with a few close
Pals pampering myself with the oh no DIY
spa night do it yourself do it yourself
okay well what does the world come to
um cooking and homemade dinner with my
family going dancing and meeting new
people I would say having a chill night
in with I'm close I'm gonna do the same
one I'm gonna say it too I'm having a
chill night with you guys yeah going
dancing meeting new people is absolutely
off the table
interacting with others on a social
setting because an ideal it depends is
this is this the weekend of my period is
it the weekend after my period it's
actually the weekend of my periods well
in that case yeah I'll be wherever
you're not okay fair enough right
because I do bite okay I guess if it's
ideal it's gonna be a night in with a
few close Pals so I thought that said
having a chill night in with a few close
pets and I just like that that is
choose another scary movie to star in a
sequel of M3 again
Candyman Friday the 13th nope a quiet
place The Shining I'm going to say a
quiet place yeah
what I love Emily Blunt she's great yeah
I'm gonna say The Shining oh I'll do a
different one I'll do uh say Friday the
13th I want to be an M3 against sequel
m4gen which I'm calling Morgan but I
want you to work with Jordan peel so
that's actually cool too it would but I
already clicked Memorial organ I'll say
no I'll say no oh no there's a sound
coming from inside the house pick a
weapon to defend yourself with is it a
lamp it's a b how big is the knife
it's basically a katana you're an yeah
it's a sword
like that whoa C golf clubs Uncle
golfing D flower face what kind of Ace
is it big
yeah it's pretty you have to overhead it
you can't one hand e can of hairspray
what size travel size half Hydro Flask
what is a Hydro Flask it's a water
bottle
it's kind of like that but yeah
someone out those things got some weight
can we put it is it like a like an
emergency like the red ones is that a
Hydro Flask like to put fires out with
what's wonderful it's like a big water
thing it's like a brand water bottle
it's a brand of water bottle but they're
hugees
it's like a big thermos so the answer is
right in front of you it's definitely
kind of hairspray because you could have
one lighter you have a flag but it
didn't say it comes with a lighter no I
don't have one I promise you where is it
I gave it to my bubble assistant well
can of hairspray do I have a lighter as
well yeah I'm gonna say golf club
I would also but also a knife I feel
like I would do a knife and a golf then
you got to get really close yeah to the
gas but you can throw the knife a throne
knife is scary yeah but then you don't
have anything
that's that's why I have the golf club
in my area it's so funny you guys didn't
say these hands
Hydro Flask if not
just told me I'm gonna do the hydro
flash just to be controversial finally
cast a celebrity to play Ghostface and
scream 7. now here's the thing we pitch
Dwayne The Rock Johnson as our dad so
with that in mind he's in this amazing
twist our dad was the killer we also
have Miss Union we have Mr Styles we
have Miss Coolidge Mr Rudd and Ms Gomez
I'm either going with Selena Gomez or
Jennifer Coolidge I'm so sorry I love
the Rock and part of I think that'd be
epic if our dad was the killer so hey
that's good for you I'm gonna go with
China for cooling we were talking about
Jennifer Coolidge recently we were yeah
but I want to act with her and live and
see her okay imagine the reveal of
Jennifer Coolidge taking the girls mask
off and then doing a whole monologue how
funny that would be without the voice I
feel like the rock would be too obvious
yeah so I'm gonna go with Jennifer
personally what are you doing I mean
obviously Harry Styles you just want to
hang out yeah I'm gonna say Paul Rudd
because I've never seen him do anything
scary and I think he would kill it I
personally am terrified of him he
doesn't age because he doesn't age
three two ones Randy me Prescott bro
final girl
final girl baby last one it's just me
and the girls final we don't die what
live forever having second hand
embarrassment the whole time
is going on the internet forever see you
there Twitter kisses
all right
cut me out of that
I'm Gail Weathers
where are you wait so we're all you're
both Carol Weathers I'm Dewey that's why
I'm in love with you too yeah it makes
total sense and we didn't even use it in
the same answer no Gail weathers that's
who I am your personality matches Gail
which is not a compliment by the way
you're strong-willed caring oh that's
nice caring and super passionate like
Gail you have a lot of ambition and
always want to succeed no matter what
sometimes you get yourself into messy
situations but you're always able to
find a way out and learn something new
about yourself people like your undying
dedication but they love your integrity
even more that's not Gale weather at all
but all right yeah they really built you
up your personality matches Dewey you're
sensitive loyal and a natural born
leader you're someone who wears your
heart on your sleeve you'll do anything
for your friends and family people
sometimes mistake your kindness for
weakness but you never fail to show
people just how powerful you really are
you're so so loved and I love David
Arquette I think you're more of a
natural-born leader than he is though
yeah I was like he's a little head in
the clouds Randy Meeks your personality
matches Randy you're smart dependable
and witty I know like Randy you tend to
question everything and everyone and hey
what can you say you're just a curious
person and that's not a crime you're
passionate about the things you love
most and people always go to you for
advice that's true because they know you
won't steer them wrong you're truly One
of a Kind now this should be in the New
York Times that's yeah that's that was
very well written Sydney Prescott your
personality matches Sydney you're strong
thank you loyal I'd like to think so and
resilient sure that's very true like
Sydney you've been through some rough
times but you always come out on top
people trust and admire you they even
sometimes wish they could be as cool as
you oh it's true as cool as when you go
I'm a woman
forever I can't even do it you did but I
like it oh there you go but I like it
by the way I I don't have the looks or
personality to even compete with Nev
Campbell that woman is a mommy and uh we
love her and do you know what that means
today does it means someone is Mommy
like Mom she's mommy no people say mommy
step on me that's what the kids say now
well I certainly wouldn't want her to
step on me
you better tell us to cut or we're gonna
really embarrass ourselves Viola Davis
my woman gang Puss in Boots
I'm sorry but that's a sexy cat
that's where we come I think we all feel
pretty good in our select yeah our
selected characters be sure to watch
Scream Six when it hits theaters March
10th bye bye bye Actually March 9th
is it yeah it'll be out March 9th that's
a Friday right the Thursday I don't know
when this movie comes out but when
screams out in theaters watch it go
watch it yeah just go sometime soon real
soon
[Music]
thank you